they're very thankful for the
consideration of the court today and uh
we're grateful for the verdicts which
have been achieved today
um our main thoughts turn to Loyal Earth
this time
um a small young beautiful girl that
shouldn't have died in her own home
Albert has been found guilty of murder
this is a horrendous heinous crime it
was a sustained violent abusive assault
of a defenseless two-year-old child
Lola had 101 injuries to a little body
and we're very grateful for our medical
experts who have been able to prove that
a large proportion of those injuries
were abusive and inflicted by Carl Bevan
the investigation has been complex and
we're grateful for our partners the CPS
so we're prosecution viruses and the
National Crime agency who've supported
us throughout to achieve an exhaustive
investigation and gather the evidence to
get the result today
James Lola's mum failed to protect her
she should have seen and foreseen or
ought to have foreseen the risk that
Kyle presented to Lawler and she should
have done something we welcomed the
verdict against Sinead as well I'd just
like to say and recognize how respectful
the families have been throughout the
investigation which has been protracted
and long they've been very disciplined
and respectful throughout so I'd like to
thank the families for supporting us
during the investigation
the police were called to the address in
half a West as a result of significant
concerns by medical professionals in
relation to the numerous injuries to
Lola which they assessed as inconsistent
to the story presented by Kyle Bevan
Carl Bevin did the seniors act he
delayed calling for any help for about
an hour and in that time he's concocted
a series of Lies making up a story of an
accidental stairfall and I'm just
grateful that the investigation with
help from our medical experts and all my
investigation team has been able to find
out the truth
Kyle is a coward he wouldn't tell us the
truth to this day you'll never know why
or how it happened but we certainly know
who did it and we welcome the Court's
consideration today I'm just going to
ask my family liaison officers now the
specialist officers who have been
supporting the family throughout just to
read some tributes firstly from Lola's
father and then from Lola's gran
on behalf of Daniel Thomas father of
Lola James the pain and grief I feel
every time I close my eyes and see your
perfect little face is unbearable the
pain I feel thinking of all the smiles
you gave to me and all the smiles I
won't get a chance to give back to you
hurts so much
even to say your name shatters my heart
to know you can't hear my voice anymore
the only reason I can stand here today
is the hope that you can see me
see that you were loved and that you
deserve to live a full happy Safe Life
surrounded by the joy that you gave to
others
I'm so sorry
your short life was filled with so much
pain you are so loved Lola and so missed
every single day
a great team with much passion has
worked together for the day since you've
left us
a special thanks to the investigation
team for not leaving any question
unanswered or stone unturned and to my
family support officers for keeping me
focused and guiding Me Through The
Darkest Hours along with my closest
friends and family
the outcome here will never stop the
hurt you felt or the hurt that lives
inside of me
it's been a long time coming to see
Justice and I can only pray that these
cruel evil people that hurt you and
allowed you to be hurt suffer pain and
torment until they take their last
breath
and on behalf of Nicola James Lola's
maternal grandmother
we would like to thank the police the
local Authority and all involved for
everything they have done to get us to
this point we will be forever grateful
for the support we have received from a
family liaison officers on the support
we have received from Sunday Bears my
last memory with Lola is here in her
singing the song Diamonds by Rihanna
she and her sister spend time learning
the song and making up a little dance to
it so that they could put on a show for
us
she will forever be our Diamond up in
the sky we will never ever forget her
and we will continue to keep her memory
alive we write her letters and we talk
to her in the sky at night
as a family we will never get over this
the loss that we feel is Indescribable
we haven't begun to process all of this
and don't know if we ever will Lola we
love you we will always love you and we
will miss you forever